翻訳: Kyoko Kamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
1995年に阪神淡路大震災が起きた時には
私はまだ学生でした
自分の子どもの頃から大好きだった街が
日本中の人が すごい美しくていいよねって
言ってた神戸の街が
崩れていくのを
ずっと悲しくて悲しくて
目を逸らせずに見ていました
あの時 6434人の方が
この街周辺ではお亡くなりになって
すごい胸の中で
お亡くなりになった方のことを思った時に
その人たちがすごく大切にしてきた
生活のステージだったこの街を
ちょっとでもいい街にするために
自分にも何かできることが
あるんじゃないかなって
ずっとそんなことを思っていました
時が過ぎて 東日本大震災の後に
数日経った時に
私 支援物資を載せてるトラックの
助手席に潜り込ませてもらって
仙台に行きました
始めのうちは結構 自分でも
役に立ったかなと思うところがありまして
また神戸での経験がありますから
緊急の時にどういうことを
しなくちゃいけないかとか
何してはいけないか
どこに行かなくちゃいけないか
何か少しずつは
判断できることがあるんですよね
でも 少しずつ緊急時から
次のステージに動いてきた時に
仙台の友達にひとつ聞かれたんです
「神戸っていったい
どうやって復興したの？」
私 全く答えられなくて ─
その時に気がついたんですね
自分の街を何とかしたい
そんなことすごく思っていたくせに
本当は何にもしていなかったことに
そこに気がつきました
今からでも何かしなくちゃという風に
思ったんですけども
こんな一人の人間が
「街の発展」みたいな大きなテーマに
いったい 何ができるんでしょうか？
ずっと それが
頭にひっかかっていました
当時の神戸は ─
私が見ていたのは
なんだかすごい活躍している人たちが
いっぱいいるんだけども
みんなバラバラだなぁという
そんな印象を受けていました
例えば ビジネスの世界で
すごい頑張っている方と
ものすごい近いフィールドで
街づくりを草の根でやってる人 ─
お互いに全く知らない
あるいは福祉の世界で
頑張っている方が
同じ対象者に対して
サービスを提供しているのに
教育の世界の方を全然知らない
知らないだけだったら
まだいいんですけども
なんか誤解してたり
勝手にお互いに距離感を感じてたり
そういうのって
今僕は神戸に対して思ったんだけども
多分いろんな街で同じことが起きてるんじゃ
ないかなっていう風に思いました
だから このバラバラをなんとかすることが
それは自分にでもひょっとしたら
できるかもしれない
そんな風に思いました
始めに思ったのは 実は
この活躍している人たちを一堂に集めて
なんかみんなで こう
次の街を考えようよっていう
そんな勉強会みたいなものを
しようかなっていう風に思いました
街づくり研究会みたいな
でも すぐに気がついたんですけども
それぞれの人が思っている街のイメージって
絶対いろいろ違うはずですし
それになんとなくハードルが高くて
マニアックな人ばっかり集まって
多分運営する僕自体が
すぐに多分つまらなくなるなって
そういう印象を持ちました
じゃあ 何ができるかな
もう一度考え直してみたんですけども
ある日フッと思いついたんですね
この活躍してる人たちを
一人ひとり先生にして
講義をしてもらっていくうちに
だんだん街の中が繋がっていって
信頼関係が生まれてきたら
みんなが協力しあえる
そんな街になるんじゃないかなって
しかも活躍している人って
必ず周りに仲間がたくさんいて
みんなをいっぺんに集めていけば
多分 繋がっていくスピードも速いし
結構大切なポイントなんですけども
「街づくり研究会にあなた参加しませんか？」
っていう風に言って回るよりも
多分「先生になってください」って
お願いする方が
僕としてもすごい言いやすいですよね
こんな風にして
「神戸モトマチ大学」は生まれました
みなさん「ソーシャルキャピタル」っていう
言葉はご存知でしょうか？
このまま日本語に無理に訳そうとすると
「社会資本」という風になります
社会資本てインフラストラクチャーのことと
区別がつかないので
「社会関係資本」そういう風に
日本語にすることが一般的です
信頼しあっている人々が
そこで繋がっていると
何かアクションを起こす時に
すごく重要な資源になるよねって
そういう考え方です
今日いらっしゃっているみなさんも
お互いに話し合って
少しわかったという今の状態から
この会場全体がみんなで
信頼関係を持てるようにまで
この会が終わるまでに
もしなったら
2〜3時間後にここに大災害が起こっても
あるいはみんなで何かしようよって
みんなで考えてもですね
多分 すごい力になりますよね
「ソーシャルキャピタル」って
そういうシンプルな考え方です
ソーシャルキャピタルには
3つのタイプがあります
左上にありますけども
いったい どれだけ有力な人と
どれだけ繋がっているんだろうっていう
人脈とかネットワーキングのようなもの
2つめが クラブとかあるいは団体
会社の中みたいな
限られた 閉ざされた空間の中で
どれだけの人が信頼関係が結ばれているか
そういう観点です
私が関心あるのは
この3つめのもの
地域社会全体に信頼が広く浸透していて
直接目の前の人のことは
あんまり知らない人だったとしても
なんとなく この地域の人だから
信頼できるなって
そういう感覚があったら
これは共有財産としての
ソーシャルキャピタルがあると
そういうことになります
これは今地域の社会を
発展させていくための基盤として
大変注目を集めています
でも すごい注目を集めているくせに
すごく残念なことなんですけども
これ どうやってこれを作ったらいいか
その方法論はどんな本を読んでも
書いてないんですよね
でも ひょっとしたら
私が偶然 神戸モトマチ大学で
始めていることが
その方法論のひとつになるかもしれない
そんな風に 今思っています
神戸モトマチ大学でやっていることは
すごい簡単で
同じ地域の中でで活躍している人を
先生にして呼んで
だいたい月に２回くらい講義をしている
そんなスタイルです
私たちは元々「この分野だけをやるんだ」
というジャンルがありますので
街中の老若男女
有名な方もそうでもない方も
それからあらゆる分野の方も
先生としてお呼びできる
そんな可能性があります
そんな特長を使って
私は神戸の街の人たちを繋げていけたら
という風に思っているんですね
全くお金の匂いがしない
そんな集まりですので
純粋に向上心がある人ばかりが
集まっています
しかも一つひとつの講義のテーマに そこに
関心があって集まってきた人ばかりですから
お互いに信頼感を作っていくそのスピードが
本当に速いなって実感しています
このようにやってること自体は
すごいシンプルなんですけども
実は講義自体が目的ではなくて
ソーシャルキャピタルを作ろう
そんな目的があるために
私たちは5つのことに
いつも意識を向けて運営しています
１つ目は「遠くから繋ぐ」ということです
この絵でいうと この左下の
繋がっているところではなくて
もっと 右上の方の遠いところから繋いでいく
そんなイメージですね
私自身の身の回りにも すごい面白いことを
研究してたりトライしてる人がいて
多分話も面白いだろうなぁという風に
そんな風に思う方─
先生にふさわしい方が
いっぱいいるんですけども
ものすごい失礼ながら
そういう方は先生として
お招きしたことがありません
いつも 講師の候補が
私の手元に来るたびにですね
Facebookをバババッと開いて
いったい共通の友達が 何人くらい
いるんだろう？って見るんですけども
数十人や数百人 共通の友達がいる方には
講師としてお招きしないんですね
もうすでに繋がってますし
そんな方よりも もうホントに
なんとなく面白そうなことをしてるんだけども
共通の友達が１人とか２人しかいない─
そんな方と一緒にお話を聞いて繋がる方が
街中が繋がっていくスピードが
ものすごく速いなって風に感じています
２つ目が「無理に集めない」ということです
あらゆるイベントが
そうだと思うんですけども
やっぱり一生懸命企画したら
たくさんの人に集まってきてほしいな
そういう風に願いますよね
そのためにちょっと楽しそうな企画を
たくさん織り交ぜてみたり
あるいは有名な方を呼んでみたり
あるいは友達中に連絡をして
来てよ来てよという風に言ったり
神戸モトマチ大学では
そういうことを避けています
むしろ 講師やテーマを 素直に見た時の
ありのままの魅力が伝わっていった方が
そこに集まってきた方々は
絶対にテンションが高[い状態で]
集まってくださいますし
お互いに共感を感じるのも
すごい速いなっていう風に考えています
たくさん繋がりたくなるのは
当たり前なんですけども
そのためには丁寧に小さい集まりを
何度も何度もしていくこと
その方が大事だなぁっていう風に
思っています
３つ目が
そうやってなんとかハードルを乗り越えて
集まってきた方を 目の前にしたら
今度は逆の話なんですけども
「無理に繋げていく」っていうことですね
無理にでも繋がるような
チャンスを作らないと
やっぱり 初めての方に自己紹介したり
自分こんなことがしたいんだっていう
話をするのは
すごい心理的に抵抗ありますよね
私自身もセミナーなんかに参加した時に
隣の人に自己紹介とか
絶対にしないタイプです
ですから プログラムの中で
なんとか隣の方と自己紹介したり
お互いの共通の関心事を話をしていく
そんな時間を取らないと
せっかく同じテーマに食らいついて
貴重な時間を割いて集まってきた方々に
申し訳ないなという風に思います
だから 「自己紹介をしましょう」と
結構そうは言っても
みなさん嫌そうな顔されたり
シーンとしたりすることがあるんですけども
本当に 集まっていただいた方々に
なんとかひとつでも多くの繋がりを
作っていただきたい
そんな思いで みなさんの嫌そうな思いを
いつも乗り越えています
次にですね せっかく集まって
楽しみに来てくださったそんな方に対しても
できる限りリピーターには
ならないでくださいって
そんなこともお願いしています
言い方としてはですね
「次にもし ものすごく関心がある
テーマがあったら
その時に是非お越しくださいね」
そんな言い方をしたりするんですけども
そもそもリピーターの方が常に
一定数いるような場所というのは
僕自身 結構行きにくいんですよね
みなさん顔見知りで なんかこう
今日のテーマに関心があるかっていうと
むしろそうではなくて
「ずっと来てます」みたいな
やっぱりそういう場になってしまうと
人と人が繋がる力というのは
私は失われていくという風に思うんですね
だからスタッフに対しても
失礼かなと思いながらも
みなさんスタッフだけども
関心がなかったら
そのテーマの時は来ない方がいいですよって
そんなことまでお願いしています
みんなが居心地が良くて
いつも同じような人ばかり来ている
その場には人と人を繋ぐ力はないなと
そんな風に考えています
最後に「私たち自身が
大きなコミュニティの中心にはならない」
それもすごく気にしています
なんだかこう
どっかに中心がいつもあって
と言うか 中心がどこにあるのか
なんとなくわかって
その中心にいつも情報が
集まっているようなところって
私 結構違和感あるんですよね
そんなことよりも
集まってくれた人々が
みんないろんな繋がりを持っていて
ハブになっていて
その成果でいろんな — 多種多様な
試行錯誤が街中で生まれている方が
絶対地域に対して
インパクトあるじゃないですか
だから 実は神戸モトマチ大学で
出会った人たちが
私やスタッフの全然知らないところで
プロジェクトを始めていて
後で「実は結構成功しかけているんだけども
こんなプロジェクト始めてるんですよ」って
そんな風に教えてくれる時に
私は本当に嬉しいなって思います
今からそんな事例をいくつかご紹介します
この左の方は
認知症などの改善のために
医療とアートの垣根を越えて作られた
臨床美術という そういう分野の講師として
[神戸]モトマチ大学で
お話しをしてくださいました
私自身もワークショップの中で
数十年ぶりに絵を描いたんですけども
本当に心を開けてくれるような ─
それでいて感性やモチベーションも
すごく花開くような
素晴らしい体験をしました
右の方はその講義を受けてくださった
看護師の方です
講義の中で臨床美術の力をすごい感じて
今では他の多くの方と一緒に
アートの力で地域を輝かせたい
そんな活動を一生懸命されています
こちらの右の方は消防士さんですけども
「普通にPRするだけで
本当に防災意識って高まるんだろうか？
何か他に方法ないのかな？」ってことを
ずっと考えている そんな方でした
左の方は地域の老舗の食品会社の方です
この二人は出会ってすぐに意気投合して
この手に持っておられる
レトルトのカレーを商品化されました
このカレーはおもしろくて
消防学校で馴染まれている─
消防学校のレストランの
カレーの味を再現しながら
パッケージ[も]すごく工夫されていて
防災意識を高められる
あるいは─
ちゃんと備えて備蓄しなくちゃいけない
そんな気持ちを高めていくような
工夫がされています
もちろんこの商品自体も
備蓄用の食品として置いておける
そんな複合的な意味を持っています
この二人はこのプロジェクトを通して
異業種の人が集まって何かをしていくと
防災意識みたいなものすごく堅くて
誰もが難しく感じていたそんなテーマも
一つ上のステージに持っていける
そんなことを体験されました
考えてみたら
自分一人で街のためにいったい何が
できるんだろうって悩んだところから
あ そうなんだ
ソーシャルキャピタル そこに専念してみよう
そういう風に思って
今ではその場で出会った方々が
いろんなプロジェクトを
花開かせてくださっています
私自身が何かしたわけではないんですけども
プラットフォームに徹することで
街の輝きを取り戻していく
そんな入り口に立てたのかなぁという風に
今では思っています
今日私は「ソーシャルキャピタル」
これをキーワードにして
それを作っていくために
５つの方法論を見出しました
そんなことをご報告しました
１つ目は 遠くからつなぐこと
そして無理には集めないこと
そして参加してくださった方には
ちょっと無理をお願いしてでも
繋がっていくチャンスを作っていくこと
リピートを求めないこと
私たち自身が中心になるのではなくて
むしろたくさんのハブができるような
そんな関係性を作っていくこと
ソーシャルキャピタルを作っていくために
別に 地域に学びの場を
作っていく必要はありませんし
この５つ以外にもたくさん方法論はある
そんな風に思います
でも最後に振り返ってみたいんですけども
これ 何一つ難しいところがないんですよね
むしろ全部すごく簡単で
でも
全部がですね ちょっとずつ
人の自然な感覚とは違う
不自然なものが多いなと
そんな印象が 私にはあります
人は 家族とか仲間とか そこと
外側の間に線を引きます
その線の内側と外側を区別していく
だから人に自然な感性のまま動いてもらうと
水が低いところに流れていくように
どうしても小さな居心地のいい
コミュニティの輪を作って
その中に閉じこもってしまいます
私自身も全く例外ではありません
だからこそ 地域中に
信頼の絆を広げていきたい
ソーシャルキャピタルを広げていきたい
そんなことを願った時には
少し 自分の自然な感覚には逆らって
意識してコミュニティとコミュニティの
境界を崩してそれをつないでいく
そんなことが必要だなぁという風に
感じています
自然にできた境界を
意識して乗り越える
そうすることで街は輝いていくと
私は信じています
みなさんの参考になれば幸いです
本日は本当にありがとうございました
（拍手）